so that went in incredible for you guys
from the outside looking in and lots of
people used it
companies found it valuable uh kind of
the capital allocator the new
uh vc uh founded valuable and then
capital partners found it valuable
uh at what point did you say wait maybe
we should actually kind of innovate on
this model
and go after the rolling funds product
yeah
so after syndicates uh there was
actually another moment where
we launched traditional funds that's a
traditional venture fund
but the real innovation there was
actually the innovation to
make a venture fund as small as possible
so usually venture funds when you start
a venture fund
there are all of these legal costs back
office costs
a counter cost says everything that need
that's needed to run a venture fund
it used to be very expensive it
literally used to be a hundred thousand
dollars a year
uh 200 000 a year just to start a fund
and by the way that's charged across 10
years so you actually got
a million dollars at least to get get a
fund off the ground
uh which means your target size will
find ends up being very large
and as soon as it's that large you like
you have to have
relationships right so in a way it kind
of restricts access to the industry
because of that so the innovation
going from syndicate to traditional
funds was how do we compress the cost
of what it takes to run a fund so
angelus managed to
we managed to compress the cost by an
order of magnitude and again it did the
same had the same impact it was like
great you were able to now bring in
a lot more uh folks into the industry
because guess what you don't need to go
raise
a 50 million dollar fund just to get
started you can actually raise a million
dollar fund
right and so we found that uh to be
very powerful and and effectively it
kind of took
the person on the journey right you
start off with syndicates you build a
track record
a reputation and then you evolve and you
go into a traditional fund and so we
kept you know
we actually stayed with them along that
journey and then with the traditional
fund they would start one
deploy the capital then go raise the
next one on number two
three etc so that was the second
innovation
that angelus uh that angelus venture
did and this was in 2016. and so from
there
uh you know we've now supported hundreds
and hundreds of these traditional funds
right so we we have
uh over time we actually built uh a ton
of infrastructure
all the way from banking infrastructure
to accounting infrastructure to
all of the software accreditation checks
everything
and from there we still noticed kind of
going back to again the theme of how do
you reduce friction right how do you
remove the steps
we still notice that the biggest
friction point
for uh anyone raising capital is the
process of raising capital it's that
when you go to raise a venture fund uh
the way the traditional venture fund the
way it works is
you basically set aside six months 12
months 18 months sometimes
to just go raise the capital and then
you're just heads down raising capital
taking all of these meetings
um all warm intros you can't talk about
it publicly because it's illegal to talk
about it publicly
and then once you raise the capital you
lock down the fund and then
you can't raise capital again into it
for the next two three four years
and we found that the there was still a
friction point on the fundraising side
meaning you still have to put in a ton
of your time kind of your energy
and uh one for people who don't have
the access meaning they don't have uh
the network of lp's to talk to
or two people who have access but like
they're just too busy
right like if you're running a company
um and
like you're not going to go through that
six month 12-month process just to go
raise capital
and so what we noticed was
you know we actually just looked at the
core of that whole thing and went
why is a structure this way right like
why do you raise
capital and then lock down the fund
because it doesn't actually make sense
uh your
your best time to raise capital is when
one of your investments has a markup
and there's so much excitement around it
right and so we just we were sitting
there
and and um it actually came through the
jam session with evolve
and naval is great at that stuff by the
way um he's probably one of the best uh
strategic strategic thinkers i've i've
met
and we're just jamming on this and and
he's like yeah you know i've had this
idea in the past
but like and question like why why are
why is this traditional fund structure
this way
why can't you just keep raising capital
and so we
kept thinking about it and we're like
you know it's interesting
the traditional venture fund structure
was built in a world
where the assumption was that people
would be doing all of the legal
back office accounting work right it was
built in a world before
software rolling funds are a venture
front structure
built in a world host software so our
view is that ruling funds
are actually a superior structure to a
traditional venture fund
meaning if software existed when the
venture fund structure was originally
built it would be a rolling front
and a rolling fund if you want you can
actually apply constraints and build a
traditional fund out of it right so it
actually is just a structure
that is it's a venture fund structure
that's built through software
that essentially has many more features
and you can choose the features and to
mix and match
mix and match the features however you
want
but it really at its core it's just a
venture fund
built through software uh and because of
that you don't need all these
constraints of
oh you need to go lock the fund down and
then go you know and then go deploy and
then raise again go to this big bang
fundraising
you can just always keep it open for
capital uh so that was a real
breakthrough moment for us
uh and and you know from there we
because we had all this infrastructure
we built up over time
uh we were able to go from idea to
initial launch
very quickly and some of the early data
that we saw was was
very very promising for us um and yeah
we just haven't looked back since we've
just been more than thrilled
by by how uh
by not just emerging managers loving the
product but also establish managers
we're seeing people coming from the vc
industry like wow this is great i don't
need to go through the
12 18 month fundraising process i could
just set this thing up
so yeah it's been great